California became the first "sanctuary
state" in the country this year when it
enacted new legislation to prevent law
enforcement from carrying out President
Trump's crackdown on the undocumented.
But now, fears here are growing amid
reports that ICE is planning to launch a
massive sweep targeting northern
California. There are almost 400,000
undocumented immigrants in the San
Francisco Bay Area alone and we're about
to visit the Oakland home of an
undocumented woman who is preparing her
family for the worst.
Wendy is a 34-year-old single mother from Honduras who cleans houses for a living.
Her two children were born in the U.S. She fled
extreme poverty and remains undocumented
after living here for 15 years. But she's
defiant, despite the threat of possible deportation.
Why are you so unafraid to
the point where you're okay showing your face?
You know, for a long time I was scared. Then, one day I said,
“Stop, no more."
She isn't only talking about ICE. Wendy's
partner was abusive for years and nearly
killed her until she ultimately escaped
with her children to a women's shelter.
Now, she only fears one thing —
deportation.
The recent threats of massive raids have prompted
Wendy and others like her to literally
prepare for their nightmare scenario.
There’s this bag.
So that duffle bag is like an emergency bag, just in case you have to go?
Yes, I just get it and that’s it.
What do you have in there? You don’t have to show me.
I have clothes for my kids – two changes for my son, two for my daughter and two for me.
Wow.
This is the card in case ICE comes to my house. I take this card, and you have it in Spanish and English.
In case ICE comes to your door.
And then how else are
you preparing? What else do you have?
I have my papers and my son’s documents. The certificate for my son and my daughter’s papers.
My passport – this is the most important, and I have it with me every day.
You know, I have the process for the U-visa, and I have with me in case something happens.
So you have everything prepared at all times with you?
Yes, I have this folder with me every day.
Are your kids scared? Or at least your son, who’s older?
Yeah, my son is scared. He cries and looks at the phone and hears other people saying,
“My mom is not from here, my mom will be deported.” He cries and says,
“I depend on you, mom. What's going on with me and my sister if you aren’t here?”
When I wake up every day, I ask him: “God, please, I pray, with my hands, take care of me and my family.”
Every day, when I go outside, I say, “I’m not scared if you’re with me, you take care of me and my family.”
And for right now, it’s worked.
Hey everyone, it's Dena. Make sure you check out more of my videos
in the Direct From playlist. Be sure to like, comment, share and subscribe to AJ+.